rosalynn gracias por su tiempo y son al
menos 100 días de activismo
ininterrumpido denunciando la brutalidad
policial y cada semana conocemos al
menos un nuevo caso de racismo contra la
comunidad afrodescendiente en medio de
este luto y del temor black life smarter
ha tomado fuerza y los ciudadanos
esperan que esta vez sí haya cambio es
realista esa esperanza
bueno muchísimas gracias por tenerme en
el programa buenos días está tempranito
acá pero en realidad yo diría que como
persona afro como un mero afro yo
siempre voy a tener esa meta de que el
mundo a trate a las personas de es negra
con respeto y no solamente que digan que
las vidas negras importan que también
entendamos que las vidas negras existen
porque hay muchas personas que están
haciendo con jon sobre lo que está
pasando y están enseñando esto esta
negatividad de la gente negra de lo que
no está pasando pero nunca han tratado
de hablar de como nosotros somos
personas que celebramos nuestra cultura
que aportamos a la comunidad pero
solamente vemos que estamos protestando
porque nos están matando y yo veo que
eso es un poquito triste que la
comunidad nacional y un lugar sólo se
concentra
en reportar solo esto que en contra del
racismo que está bien pero antes de
antes de también hacer cosas así hay que
hablar de cosas como estamos haciendo en
el donde yo vivo aquí en washington dice
ya yo he tenido esas conversaciones con
mis estudiantes que son
afrodescendientes yo como mujer afro
latina
que aquí les decimos a flor latina
porque vivo acá pero como mujer latina
veo que también en muchas comunidades de
habla hispana
nosotros los afro latinos no nos apoyan
en ese en ese aspecto de que las piedras
negras importan que las vidas negras
existan rosalynn estamos en una época
electoral en eeuu con donald trump a que
amplía la presencia de la fuerza
nacional en las ciudades que son foco de
protesta y con un joe biden que culpa a
los republicanos por el aumento de la
violencia sin embargo lo que está
demostrado es que esta violencia racista
no solamente es histórica sino que
además es sistemática porque no ha
podido según su opinión eeuu superar
esta crisis
porque en eeuu aquí como inmigrante me
fijado que aquí sólo se concentran en el
aporte económico y no se concentra en
una persona como persona en este país
todo es que tienes que tener una
certificación tienes que tener
suficiente dinero aquí no hay cualidad
de vida cuando tú eres un inmigrante en
el país de nosotros
la gente celebran esa es como ahora es
libre de wii que acá pero acá hay mucha
gente que están trabajando en este país
no la gente no saben hacer pausa y ya
llamar la vida en este país es solamente
si tú eres una persona negra y era una
mujer y eres inmigrante vas a tener que
trabajar mucho más fuerte y el problema
con el tram sismo sistemático es
y lo hacen como uno
es como cositas que hacen en el sistema
que te bloquean para tu seguir adelante
que te quitan que te quitan tiempo como
tú como madre para tú pasar tiempo en tu
casa con tus niños para decirle mira el
mundo es de cierta manera pero con
respecto de las elecciones yo estoy
esperando que el donald trump lo quiten
porque donald trump sinceramente es
común muchos de los políticos que veo en
latinoamérica y yo bien eeuu para vivir
en un país de democracia para vivir en
un país en libertad y no para
estar como con una burocracia y con un
sistema que por el color de mi piel me
no me quitaron apoyo